you don't have one of these what you
don't have a code switch no how does it
coach work well it's a little tricky but
let me break it down for you Jack Knight
comedian and voice of fan favorite
character Devon and the Netflix animated
series big mouth has died he was 28.
come on Devin you know this is my spot
Devon I just didn't think that you could
golf anymore with your rheumatoid
arthritis I'm not an old man according
to multiple reports the actor and writer
died Thursday night in Los Angeles his
family who confirmed the tragic news did
not release the cause of death or the
circumstances surrounding his death they
have asked for privacy Jack was a rising
star and his sudden death caught
Hollywood by surprise fellow comedian
Camille nagiani tweeted quote rest in
peace Jack Knight hilarious comedian and
a great guy I can't believe it following
the news of Jack's passing Comedy
Central also tweeted quote Jack Knight
was a hysterical and honest comedian we
will miss him tremendously
at 28 Jack managed to already make a
name for himself in the stand-up World
opening for comedians like Dave
Chappelle along with voicing Devon's
character for five seasons on big mouth
he also was a writer for the show cause
when you're young and black you develop
a knack for putting the world at ease
I got a different me for every situation
Jack is also credited as a writer for
the ABC hit show blackish and more
recently he co-created and starred in
peacock's bust down opposite of Chris
red samjay and Langston Kerman whoa you
were there you didn't jump in and help
bro that part bust down is an unfiltered
comedy series about four friends who are
working dead-end jobs but nevertheless
they don't allow it to steal their Joy
the comedy series was only in its first
season premiering back in March